FEMALE SPEAKER: What word
best describes a designer?
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL: Um--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Wow.
One word?
MATIAS DUARTE: One word.
You want me to say one word?
RICHARD THE: What word
best describes a designer?
DUSTIN SENOS: Can
I make a word up?
Solutioner.
BRYNN EVANS: Creative.
SOLEIO CUERVO: Creator.
MAYKEL LOOMANS: Problem solver.
MIA BLUME: Problem solver.
SHALIN AMIN: Storyteller.
ANDRE PLAUT: I think
the word "synthesis."
MICHAEL RENAUD: Punchline.
JONATHAN LEE: Dexterous.
RICHARD THE: Thoughtful.
SCOTT DOORLEY: Intentional.
ENRIQUE ALLEN: Intentional.
JON WILEY: Inquisitive.
MICHAEL ROCK: Curious.
TYSON EVANS: Curious.
MATIAS DUARTE: Optimistic.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Inventive.
RACHEL BEEN: Neurosis.
MARK KAWANO: Unsatisfied.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What do you
consider to be good design?
TYSON EVANS: I mean, the
best design's invisible.
SHALIN AMIN: Invisible.
KOEN BOK: Design that
you don't really notice,
but you start remembering
it for being good,
because it was
never in your way.
DUSTIN SENOS: Frictionless.
MAYKEL LOOMANS: You design
as little as possible.
MICHAEL RENAUD: Less design.
JONATHAN LEE:
Appropriate design.
JON WILEY: Design is not art.
Design is about
solving problems,
and so I think a good design
solves an important problem
to people.
RACHEL BEEN: It's a product
that solves a user's need.
VIVIAN ROSENTHAL: A
solution to something
that should be designed,
not just designed
for design's sake.
BRYNN EVANS: Good design
is thoughtful and thorough.
CLARK VALBERG: Crystallizing
all of the conversations
that need to happen to really
fully realize a strategy.
SOLEIO CUERVO: Operating not
just at the surface level,
but creating rich, engaging,
beautiful experiences,
but really thinking through,
how does this product,
how does this service, fit
within a person's life?
ANDRE PLAUT: Solves a problem
while motivating people
to do more.
MATIAS DUARTE: Solves
people's problems and touches
them emotionally
at the same time.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Something that's
beautiful, and functional,
and immediately says
what it does, what it
is, what it's there for.
DANIEL BURKA: Design
that makes products
that help people's lives,
make people's lives easier.
MARK KAWANO: If it moves
somebody in some way,
that's good design.
MIA BLUME: Hopefully, it's
delightful and beautiful.
But at the end of the day, if
it didn't solve the problem,
it didn't work.
SCOTT DOORLEY: Being intentional
to help other humans.